I love no man's sky and I can totally
understand why someone would hate it my
purpose here isn't to convince you that
it's a game you should buy or a game you
should enjoy playing but to try and
impart a sense of understanding so that
you can see what it is that I find
appealing about no man's sky
no man's sky is a very lonely game which
really isn't all that unusual on its
face most single-player games are
ultimately a little lonely even when
they try to fill in the hole of human
companionship but unlike a game in the
mould of Skyrim or Fallout 4 games where
you are surrounded by
computer-controlled simulacra trying and
generally failing to convince you of
their humanity no man's sky makes no
pretensions to companionship it is
lonely on purpose aggressively so indeed
this if anything could be isolated as
the core theme of the game the
experience begins with the player waking
up next to a wrecked ship a very trophic
video game in media res the player
inhabits a silent protagonist with no
history who ventures forth to do
whatever they want really at the surface
this is all very typical framing a set
up that any experienced videogame
enthusiasts would feel quite comfortable
with where it diverges from the typical
is that over the course of hours as the
player encounters NPCs uncovers lost
relics and unearths ancient mysteries it
is made quite clear that the player
isn't just a convenient blank slate they
are in fact an outsider the biggest
expression of this is through one of the
core goals of the game learning the
various words of the four species that
inhabit the galaxy because you see you
don't speak their languages and they
don't speak yours your character
referred to only vaguely as the
traveller or perhaps more generically as
a traveler not a member of unique group
but simply an adjective isn't from here
wherever that happens to be whenever the
player encounters someone or something
that does speak the same language of
them the writing calls attention to that
fact highlighting it it is expressly
made to be something unusual something
that causes notice and defies
expectation by and large the other
members of the galaxy treats you like a
very confident lost child they're not
sure you really know what you're doing
but you seem to be able to take care of
yourself well enough so not my problem
the individuals you encounter will
generally help you but most of the time
it's very quid pro quo the corvax a
machine race of plural entities are the
most helpful but simultaneously the most
patronizing the gack are perhaps the
most respectful treating you as appear
but really it's more like a customer
lastly the bike cream now they're the
only species that treats you like you're
special due to an
ancient cultural belief that travelers
shouldn't be burdened but in practice
this isn't so much chosen one as much as
it is refrain from killing you and
taking your things your experiences with
individual NPCs are all very
disconnected in time you aren't building
a history or a relationship this isn't a
stepping stone to friendship love
companionship or simulated AI trust
there is no dialogue tree of gift-giving
to unlock the sexy cutscene you're not
special no matter where you go you're
not there to stay you are always
displaced always out of place just a
traveler passing through but even in
that your avatar isn't special because
it's no man's sky no one belongs
anywhere there are no cities no
permanent residences just prefab spartan
dormitories drop from space like
confetti across the landscape if you
should happen across one of the few bars
or lounges there empty saved maybe the
single NPC stationed there this is
codified in the text of the game
characters talk with each other but it's
always remote always physically distant
a phone call or an email the sole
exception here are two key NPCs pollo
and nada a pair of time-displaced
scientists who are unique among all the
people you meet in the game first they
speak your language and second they're
in the same room together these two
acknowledge that there is something off
about the universe that things are too
simple too structured that there is
something fundamentally spiritually
wrong and it's impacting everyone in a
bit of metatextual line blurring they
suggest it's all just a simulation
perhaps a product of the atlas or maybe
something else one of the subtler ways
this theme is reinforced this idea that
you don't belong is the life-support
module as a game mechanic your character
wears a life-support suit that protects
them from various hazards including
extreme temperatures radiation toxic
atmospheres and so on and you can never
take it off no matter how perfect a
world how temperate fertile and lush you
can never take off your life support
it's always there ticking away even the
most serene planet in the galaxy cannot
be home they are all killing you it's
just a question of how slowly
so you can visit but you can't truly
stay the only place you are freed from
the constraint of your life support
module is in space in your ship or on a
Space Station the looming entropy abates
but space stations are truck stops and
besides someone else already lives there
so that leaves you with your ship as the
closest thing to call home this combines
with other mechanics to create a
constant gentle forward pressure an
element that is being criticized by many
as the lack of a local mini-map went on
a planet surface which makes it
decidedly difficult to find your way
back to anything that isn't marked by a
HUD icon you stumble across a drop pod
offering a valuable but costly inventory
upgrade but you can't afford it so you
jump in your ship to go sell off
minerals at a nearby trade port only to
get disoriented on the way back is this
frustrating yes in the moment it can be
quite frustrating but bear with me for a
second
the game is training you it is putting
you in a position with set of incentives
that push you towards a desired response
the game deprives you of the tools to
stay in one place to settle down to get
comfortable because it wants you to feel
Restless to feel compelled to let go and
move on I think the most curious thing
that no man's sky does with its sense of
loneliness stems from the online
features and subtle nods to the fact
that the player is alone but not unique
you will on occasion stumble across logs
that are in your language left behind by
other doomed travelers in their final
moments these logs always veer towards
horror and reinforce the players
reliance on their life-support module
with tales of infection and
contamination then there's the online
features as the player comes across
various things solar systems planets
animals plants minerals they're given
the option of naming those things and
uploading their names to somewhere
diegetic Lee it's unclear where exactly
these uploads go but the player can
encounter systems that others have been
through and left their thumbprint on
it's nothing monumental nothing that
will alter the flow of the universe or
tip the scales of power you're too small
to do anything like that
you can't realign the world of no man's
sky any more than you can alter the
course of the earth by stomping on the
ground really hard you can at most
scratch your name in the bark in the off
chance someone else happens to drive by
dan was here you're not entirely alone
because there's the rub it's one thing
to be literally entirely alone
constrained into an isolated impermeable
sandbox you adjust fallout doesn't
create a sense of existential loneliness
because you know that you're alone
that's the simple immutable reality you
expect to be alone it's the tease that
makes no man's sky so much more potent
you're alone in public there is in
theory someone else out there somewhere
maybe possibly now stepping outside the
poetics of the system there's a very
real possibility that the game has no
framework for any substantial player
interaction at least two players have
managed to be in theoretically the same
place at the same time with no result
and while hello games have implied that
there's some dimension of player
interaction we haven't seen yet because
the central servers were too overloaded
by the launch to run it it's not clear
what that might even entail the
practical reality is that it's not going
to be a thorough persistent simultaneous
experience they didn't stealthily create
an MMO so there's a very real
probability that this element boils down
to little more than an illusion but I'm
okay with that so much of effective
storytelling is illusion
Mass Effect doesn't try to create
authentic relationships it simply tries
to create things that feel like
authentic relationships every game has a
phase where it's new and shiny and
unknown where systems are still obscured
and the collective minds of the player
base have yet to unravel every
interaction document every decision and
solve every mechanical choice now many
games do continue to be fun beyond that
point but there's still something
special that exists in that space of
uncertainty that once dispelled can
never be recreated and this was the
space that I had the pleasure of
experiencing no man's sky within an
unsolved world plagued by melancholy it
is not a difficult world true threats
are few and far between but that in and
of itself makes it unique no man's sky
calls on a lot of the shared language of
survival games complete with the myriad
user interface bars that all slowly tick
but we're don't starves many bars for
health sanity hunger and cold all Harold
and almost certainly permanent demise no
man's sky isn't weighted with such dire
stakes its sense of survival is more
mundane and ensconced in a series of
maintenance rituals top up your life
support top up your fuel hunt for iron
and plutonium recharge your mining being
recharge your engines take a shower
brush your teeth get dressed
face the day it's no surprise then that
no man's sky appeals to me given that it
calls on a lot of other themes that I
already enjoy it
reminisces of early modest mouse albums
both in literal musical quality and in
tone and shared subject matter no man's
sky could as well be renamed it's a long
drive for someone with nothing to think
about
or perhaps the moon in Antarctica 65
days of statics work collectively titled
music for an infinite universe would
mesh perfectly on a mixtape with
Dramamine and the stars or projectors
the road trip is perhaps no man's Sky's
most obvious analog I had already
written the majority of this script
before I left for PAX West in Seattle
and it was on my mind often during the
26 hours I spent in space between
Calgary and Seattle
there's a lot of space in there and much
of it washes right out of the mind but
there is intersperse to the occasional
uninspiring vista magnificent sunset or
dreamlike moment there's also people but
they're usually distant in their own
vehicles there's the cashiers at truck
stops and drive throughs and gas
stations but you're not there to become
companions or make friends you're just
passing through alone in public